carlos canascard is an unlikely literary
celebrity the norwegian novelist is the
author of the best-selling six-volume
novelized memoir my struggle min comp
and norwegian title deliberately and
somewhat controversially borrowed from
adolf hitler's autobiography mein kampf
as kanasgard readily acknowledges
they're books without much of a plot or
quotidian events are described with
exacting and sometimes exhausting detail
in norway a country of just five million
people my struggle has sold 450 000
copies
english language critics regularly
compare him to proust and await the
translation of each new volume with
child-like anticipation
we met carlova in new york days before
the release of my struggle book 4.
what is your writing
schedule i mean you get up fairly early
and try to produce a certain amount of
words a day or yeah i get up at 4 00 4
30 and i write before the kids
water yeah
that's the best part of the day so i
have two three hours before they wake up
and then i have to take them to school
and so on
and then i write a little bit later but
the major part is in the morning it's
done in the morning yeah
how do like norwegians think of you
at this kind of global celebrity that's
kind of happened to you it has been so
much about me in norwegian papers and
norwegian media that i think people are
you know sick and tired of it they don't
want they want to don't want to hear
anything more
i'm sorry
um
you don't sell that many books you can't
just be giving money out to people
but i don't have any on me so
i would have given another west no but i
think that's that's how it is i don't
think this has anything to do with young
it's just that it's too much it's too
much
you know when i cut my hair when it was
uh at the worst when i cut my hair it
was one page and the papers
really and when i bought my house there
were journalists taking pictures of the
house before we moved in they were in
interviewing the neighbors you know this
was half a year a year when it was like
that no it's it's not anymore but so
that's but that's died down a little bit
yeah but i mean it's become more global
now though hasn't it yeah it has i mean
if you don't have social anxiety though
do you no i don't but it's just you know
i'm not very good at speaking with
people uh and i think my body language
signalized that i don't i'm not
interested even though i am but isn't
that just a scandinavian thing
yeah yes it is but i think i have i have
more of it yeah so
no sorry what i do is that
i like to be
in a room by myself
i try not to think about people that
people know anything about me
and i succeed in that there's a word for
into english kind of
as a repression or yeah yeah so yeah
yeah that's that's what i do yeah and
it's a way of staying
that's a really strange thing to hear
and i think uh a strange people i mean
people would think that was odd somebody
who's written
3 000 plus pages about themselves
exposing themselves yeah and this idea
that you don't want people to know about
you yeah but that's in a novel you know
and when you write a novel there's
nobody there and it's like
this is the only possible way for me to
express myself is through a novel i
think
where i could be free and i can't say
that in any social setting i am not free
okay so why wouldn't you do this why
wouldn't you write the books where you
feel
write these manuscripts where you feel
that this is the only place you can
really be free and why just why
publish that's because i am a novelist
you know that's what novelists do yeah
and uh
it is really for me a piece of art in a
way it is literature it is yeah you know
it is uh
it's not me it's not my life it is
something objective to it yeah very much
so
indeed it's
that's why i'm doing it i try to make
novels yeah
let's uh go get a drink yeah so can we
do that in the middle of the day that's
okay one drink is okay one drink is over
one rank is okay
i don't like writing i like having
written i see do you do you actually
enjoy the process of writing is it a
painful
kind of like giving birth thing it's
painful in the beginning very much so
with a
white
that's terrible that's absolutely
terrible staring back at you yeah and
you have this idea of what you're going
to achieve and it's going to be great
you know i've been thinking for this for
a year and then you start and you see
now this is crap you know and you know
it and it keeps
staying as that's great as crap for
maybe months you know and that's hard
but then i start to enjoy it
what is the point where you started
enjoying it at the point where i start
to lose
track of myself and and what i'm doing
and just disappearing into something
yeah thank you thanks
and that's the only joy of writing
that's to disappear for yourself i find
it hard to
i mean i find that i write badly and i
i do that all the time and i need
someone to say no this is good
constantly so i have to have some people
to say that to me around me which is the
only way i can
actually have the stamina to write is if
someone's
sort of looking at your stuff and you're
giving an affirmation yes yeah only
that's what i do i write very much about
nothing and it's very hard to to see the
value of that for myself you know so for
instance when i wrote for junior times
which
terrified me i was so afraid
and i started to write and it was about
nothing and it was really nothing and i
couldn't i needed to have someone to say
but this is good
and so i could
write for another day and then i need
that confirmation again
and you wrote they wanted what like i
said 10 pages of written text and you
ended up writing what i brought 70 and i
didn't dare to tell them you know i
didn't i didn't have the guts to tell
them that this is going to be a bit
longer so on the day of the deadline i
get my agent to say well he has written
70. this is the wonderful thing about
success is you have all these people
that can they can intervene in these
uncomfortable situations and do it for
you this is the first time i've used
you know it's the first time i've done
that
and it was it was good and that so that
comes out tell me what this is like this
comes a huge newspaper
the reaction is for people who read the
just they're sunday newspaper readers
they're not necessarily familiar with
your work
and they say
what's going on here yeah something's
got to happen right this is about
nothing and the reaction is is
mixed but you don't pay attention to
those reactions i saw uh you know the
number of comments to it but for me it
was completely you know uncontroversial
i was just writing i saw nothing and i
was writing about that
and i was very bothered when i traveled
through the us because i know this i
don't have a story there is nothing i
don't see anything it's you know yeah
and then i have to write that and that's
the story yeah and i still feel bad
about it but that's what it was you do
yeah
the times was happy with it the people
that read it were
broadly happy with them
yeah
but so this weighs on you in some way
that you could have done this in a
different it could have been better it
could have been something could have
happened yeah yeah i could have talked
to someone you know or or
presented something i had a theory about
something or because they wanted
something big i guess but isn't that
they know what i mean if you
say to anybody who has read your work or
knows something about you
carlo can escort what does he do you say
well he writes these books about himself
that are also something that they're
also about nothing to there could be
meandering yeah kind of bits about going
and getting something out of the
refrigerator so there's an expectation
this is what you do right that's how you
write it but that still makes you feel
sorry yeah miserable yeah
it's like this i uh as everybody wants i
want to be clever and i want to you know
to be admired for my
for being clever in a way and in writing
you do that but it's hard to wrap your
head around because you say you know you
want to be clever you want to be
brilliant you're one of your heroes as
produced you're consistently compared to
proofs by people who are
worth listening to
and that has no
i mean i know bruce i've read bruce i
know what he can do and i
can't do that i mean
so it doesn't matter who says it you
just no believe it no
so did you know the headlander norwegian
post and that's like you know a
contradiction in
different terms it's impossible it
really is impossible and i really admire
puss right yeah if i could you know
and i had a kind of a sorrow when i
ended my struggle because this was my
chance to do something like that this
was the story of my life you know yeah
you know
in fact it it was it wasn't
you understand how that makes me feel if
that is a failure it's like i think of
like jesus christ i'm you know i'll
never achieve anything even close to
that there's nothing that i can imagine
would be as successful as that for me no
but that success is you know that's
something out there that's
separated right yeah yeah very much so
yeah yeah
and from happiness too right it has an
influence doesn't it i mean being
successful makes you slightly happier
have so many many advantages
you know yeah and so many doors that are
yeah open which is brilliant yeah but it
doesn't help anything with my mental you
know state of mind how happy are you
i woke up every morning being unhappy
every morning every morning consistently
yeah with this feeling of when was the
last time you woke up and you said i'm
sort of reasonably happy doesn't happen
and then takes
some hours and and i
and it gets better you know at the end
of the day it's okay
so it is then i you know i but you just
accept this this is just part of
yeah and is is writing
sort of is helping is it yeah it's a
cliche but it's therapeutic in some ways
yeah and not what i write but just the
act of writing that's yeah that's that
helps uh because i forget myself yeah
you know but with success comes
you know these other
anxieties you go to san francisco last
week
to talk about volume four of my struggle
how many people showed up to talk to me
i just felt 100 1200 people
what's that moment like when you i have
to be there to amuse and entertain 1200
people it's the moment of horror
it's i get so nervous i almost throw up
you know
and it's it's
it's terrifying and it is terrifying
talking to 20 people
so it's absolutely it's terrible you're
a very very successful writer and it
seems like a sort of perfect storm but
this does not fit your personality at
all but i still have some elements in my
personality i mean i have kind of a
narcissistic
part of me and that's part of it i want
to be seen as well you know and it's
it's very contradictory
it's full of ambivalence
i mean is it difficult for you
the books come out in norway the
response to this
is very positive
and this is kind of soil you've tilled
quite a bit
but it's also
one of
anger
yeah people that are clearly identified
i don't know wanted to sue you or
something and there's people getting
lawyers there's people denouncing you in
the press yeah is that that's that's a
sort of different type of anxiety i mean
writing this book is a clarifying
experience for you it's it's therapeutic
in so many ways and then it comes out
and then that
i mean how did you respond to that yeah
i didn't you know think about that when
i was writing the first two books but
then i sent a copy out to the people
i've been writing about
and then i got a reaction and they said
you can't publish it we will stop you
we'll use all means to stop you from
publishing these illegal names yeah they
said so
and then we just had lawyers reading
everything and it was kind of a and then
i realized what i've been doing and and
the rage and anger against me was you
know i wanted to be liked
yeah that's kind of a basic thing but i
could have said okay i won't publish but
i did so it was a maybe a two weeks time
where i was discussing this thinking
through this ethically morally can i do
it you know what i've been doing was i
wrote about my father and my grandmother
your father died in 1998 though right
yeah yeah yeah
and so this was a
this was his family yeah
they were the most yeah upset yeah they
were very upset
but what i said to myself was
they can't deny me telling the story of
my father that's yeah they can't do that
but of course it's it's um
i inflict pain on people and i
that's um
how many ruptured relationships from
this book that's this is the half of my
family so it cities have you yeah yeah
and it's and it's some
friends some friends yeah yeah but not
many friends um
almost everybody accepted it and yeah
and
some were angry for a few days but
that was okay
let's talk about the books a little bit
i mean there's
endless discussion of the actual
title of the book
and
every piece seems to start with the same
kind of paragraph there was one in
interview magazine the other day you
know my struggle is a struggle to read
because it's there's a lot of tdm in it
and then a ref and then a discussion of
the actual
the actual title itself
if you skip ahead to the sixth book
you have like a 200 page digression
and it's talking about mein kampf and
talking about adolf hitler and
august kubizek his childhood friend and
all this stuff what was the
why i guess is the very short question
of it
you know it's a book it's a book about
yourself it's about you i start off i'm
reading about
your father and then i'm ending on
200 pages on adolf hitler yeah
it's uh
the first five books forms a circle it
starts and ends with the funeral of my
father book six is about the
consequences of those flag books
and one of the consequences was that i
used the title
my camp
my struggle
so i had to i had to read hitler's book
and i did and you read and you actually
read the entire thing yeah yeah
this book is also about the relationship
between reality and literature
another fitness book is maybe the book
that's kind of crossed those lines most
yeah
and led by that i started to write about
it i thought i should write 10 pages but
it kind of you know i was so interested
in it so start started
writing about hitler as a young man and
i realized yeah well there's a lot of
similarities between hitler as a young
man and me as a young man yeah that's
the most jarring thing you don't read
stuff like that
about this sort of humanizing in some
way and people comparing themselves to
adolf hitler yeah i mean was the
reaction to that
not to that i think
but there was a reaction to you know
after the massacre in norway
there was all these people were gathered
the hundreds thousands of people were
gathered for the first time for many
many years in oslo you know and i
compare that to
i've
it was so good to be a part of a nation
it was a good to be a part of that it
felt like a wee you know and i compared
that to nazism because i knew there must
be something very good in there you know
because people wouldn't have gone there
if it was only bad you know someone's
been joy it must have been something
very good and i compare that to
those two you know episodes
with each other and that was a headline
you you are an incredibly intelligent
man you know exactly what's happening
when you write that you know that that's
going to drive people crazy right
no i didn't think of that it's not just
honestly i didn't think that i thought
this is this is true and finally i found
some truth in there of course somewhere
in me i knew this is this is the kind of
provocation but that wasn't
that wasn't the motivation for writing
this is this is what i do you stop
yourself from writing things if you
think that it might i mean as somebody
who's very conscious of what people are
thinking of them is everything that
comes out from here come onto the page
without you stopping yourself no it has
to be true i have to you know have to
know this is true yeah then i could do
it no matter consequences but it has to
be can't be you know i'm saying this
to gain something it must be true
because when you open the book and i see
you talking about ian kershaw and then i
go back five pages
and i see two words on the page that
screaming out at me
no okay and i see these and like and
then somewhere down i see hitler yeah
what is the context of that
context yeah the context of like you're
talking about i mean this is about words
that one cannot say
things that one cannot say is that what
the i don't really remember you don't
remember i don't remember it no
you honestly don't no i don't i'm sorry
really yeah but it's so many pages you
know it's
they're yours right yeah but i'm sorry
damn that's surprising to me but it is
like if you if you try not to reflect
when you're writing it's almost like you
are dreaming when you're writing you
know so it's it's not so strange and it
was the last one you wrote and it's the
more sort of academic part of it yeah
was that enjoyable
yeah that was the only really enjoyable
part was it was yeah that was really a
joy to write about all of hitler
why because it's um
it's uh because it's not about you it's
not about me and it's something
completely new to me and isn't like an
exploration into a new territory and i'm
very interested in
what was going on there you know when i
i think i found out something it's kind
of a cultural psychology involved here
which i never thought of did the times
ecology
and then the experience of the first
world war which must have been
absolutely
terrible for them and destroy their
their sense of value of life you know
and then he rise up you know and he can
express those feelings for everybody
that was what he was doing i just tried
to figure out why how you know
and i think i could understand it
quite good
you know it is
never-ending discussion i see
of your politics
does this surprise you or that
or do you
not care at all uh i'm not interested in
in that aspect no i'm not the irony from
the very beginning calling this book my
struggle was that this struggle is that
you know little little small struggles
that we all have and all know but but to
be clear you read mind conf after you
named the book yeah yeah i had to you
know because of that yeah so i did read
it
so
um that's kind of the only political
statement i'll make this is this is and
that's i think that's the role of art
that's what art
is anti-politics and it's you know
in its core
uh but no i'm not right-wing what is the
thing that drives people to say that
about you the two two topics you can't
really talk about if you don't say the
exact right things
and that's immigration
and that's
gender and i'm touching both in the
books
so
that's the reason why
the fourth volume's out now in the us
this is about your teenage years mostly
yes that's right yeah the age of 16 to
19 something the basic topic in the book
i think is identity that is
and childhood is kind of
an area we don't have any identity you
just exist you know and then you then
you kind of come to terms with who you
are who your parents are in the teenage
years which is very interesting
for the first time you want to have sex
you can't you don't really know what it
is and there's a lot of you in this book
trying to find that like where do i get
sex basically yeah
and what is this you know yeah and it's
such a drive in the life it's such an
important thing
you are completely occupied with it and
it's so difficult so i'm fascinated by
that period in my life so it was very
easy to write about i i remembered
everything instantly how it was even if
the memories are you know faked or or
not it doesn't matter right it's what's
inside there's a film script
yeah
tell us about that there's your first
novel's being adapted what's going on
with that who's who's doing that i have
a
friend who's a director called felik
hedfelt
so he's going to direct it and i'm
writing the script
they're just waiting for the script i've
been waiting for a year
uh and i haven't are you having trouble
producing it
i find it very hard to write
this the opposite writing and i will
write the script but i'm getting better
at it but it still is lacking something
it is a different language you know and
i don't master that language yeah i mean
the first draft i sent to the director
of fredericki just laughed at me i just
laughed i mean
what is this i mean all the characters
are kind of presenting themselves hello
my name is you know and i'm this you
know
and then he explained to me okay this is
not how you do it you just jump in there
and everybody will understand everything
just by and then okay and then i tried
that and yeah it's getting better but
still is
it's very difficult very hard you mean
you can't explain anything you know in
in writing you just explain it yeah this
is how it was that's the right thing you
can't do that you have
it's exciting if it's very hard
what have you moved on to
what are you working on mostly i have um
i'm writing one text each day
through a year about i mean i get up in
the morning four o'clock in the morning
and i pick just one word or one object
and i write one page about that
so it's no psychology it's no no people
it's just things tell me the last one
you wrote what it was uh should have
been you know toilet chair
uh the toilet itself yeah how it looks
what it does how it works
like you never seen it before you know
or vomit
or tree or sun and i try to make all the
things i mean we
have a hierarchy of things you know
something is good something is bad but
try to you know crush that and have
equality so everything is
of the same value so it's just
just for fun
almost and i need to escape from the
psychology of but in the more in the
sense of a more traditional novel which
you've obviously done too that's what
i'm going to do now yes yeah that's
that's what i'm this is just some i
think that i do in the morning and then
i'll write a novel during the day
that's the that's the plan that's the
plan yeah
and it's going to be something
not realistic not
has nothing to do with me whatsoever
it's going to be very different thank
you thank you it was really nice
you